pues su máximo negociador ha salido
justo de terminar la reunión hace algo
más de una hora hablar con la prensa de
dicho cuestiones muy interesantes ha
dicho sobre todo que ucrania se muestra
dispuesta a renunciar a su hipotética
entrada en la otan y asegurar a su
posición de neutralidad entre la otan y
rusia y además ha dicho que también se
muestra dispuesta a no obtener bases
militares extranjeras en su país a
cambio de esto ucrania pide un consejo
de garantías en los que haya una mesa
negociadora con ocho países aparte de
ucrania son entre ellos eeuu el reino
unido canadá francia polonia e incluso
la misma turquía que de hecho se muestra
dispuesta a ello además también ha
explicado el jefe de negociación
ucraniano que ucrania está también
dispuesta a aceptar un periodo de
negociación de 15 años para dirimir en
un futuro el futuro de las regiones de
crimea ocupada por rusia desde 1914 y
donets y luján son desde ese mismo año
hay dos repúblicas semi independientes
dependientes
de mosco ha dicho ucrania que durante
estos 15 años de negociación ucrania se
mostraría perfectamente dispuesta a
comprometerse a no realizar ninguna
actividad militar contra estas dos
regiones y a aceptar esta ocupación rusa
durante ese tiempo por lo tanto
establecer un sistema negociador
muchísimo más tranquilo con un moscú que
de momento se muestra dispuesto a ello
pero no hay ningún tipo de respuesta
porque estas propuestas ucranianas son
puntos que propone ucrania no hay un
texto aún firmado sin embargo podría
estar algo más cerca que lo estaba hace
unas horas antes de la reunión en
estambul